[Aplausos]
muchas gracias
yo me describo a mí mismo como un
epidemiólogo nutricional epidemiólogo
nutricional es el que estudia las
enfermedades relacionadas con la
nutrición pero a nivel de poblaciones
epidemiología la ciencia que estudia las
poblaciones más que a los individuos y
uno pensaría que estudiar epidemiología
poblacional que es estudiar cómo
prevenir la obesidad la diabetes y las
enfermedades cardiovasculares pues no
podría tener más que apoyo de toda la
sociedad un tema de trabajo como no sé
cómo la paz mundial donde todo el mundo
pues coinciden en que son objetivos
importantes desafortunadamente no es así
hay muchas fuerzas y muchos actores
sociales que están en desacuerdo con las
propuestas que uno trata de hacer para
prevenir y controlar los problemas de la
obesidad y la razón es que se afectan
muchos intereses se afectan muchos
intereses económicos cuando uno trata de
modificar las políticas este anécdota
que les voy a contar es de algo que pasó
en febrero de 2017 yo acabé saliendo en
la portada del new york times' de una
edición del domingo con
y todo porque junto con otros
científicos fuimos víctimas de espionaje
en mexico en nuestros teléfonos y esto
es porque estuvimos participando en el
desarrollo y en el impulso al impuesto a
las bebidas azucaradas esto a mí me
enseñó algo que pues es una reflexión
que es un poco triste pero pero es muy
verdadera y es que en algunas
circunstancias trabajar por la salud
puede llegar a ser muy peligroso pero
ante este tipo de cosas lo que ha pasado
con los investigadores y con los
científicos con los activistas y con los
políticos que estaban trabajando en el
impuesto es que decidimos salir públicos
ante este problema denunciarlo y le
vamos a echar el doble de las ganas
porque queremos que haya una mejor salud
para el país pero déjenme comentarles un
poco de por qué es importante lo que
hago han oído mucho de
de casos de gran superación que inspiran
mucho de cómo ser un mejor individuo
pero yo quiero platicarles de cómo
podemos hacer un mejor país
no hay un motor más efectivo de pobreza
en el país que las enfermedades crónicas
esto no lo digo yo acabo de estar este
mes en copenhague y lo presento un grupo
de expertos en una de las mejores
revistas del mundo en la revista lancet
y se concluye que no se van a alcanzar
los objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
como reducción de pobreza equidad
igualdad de género bienestar salud no se
van a alcanzar más de 9 objetivos si no
se logra reducir las enfermedades
crónicas como obesidad y diabetes por
esto es tan importante pero no sólo eso
imagínense un secretario de economía que
no le importa la salud dice no es que yo
a mí lo que me importa es disminuir la
pobreza y lo que me importa es el
desarrollo económico bueno una de las
formas más importantes de desarrollar un
país y una de las inversiones más
efectivas es también invertir en
enfermedad en reducir las enfermedades
crónicas y esto lo sabemos hay estudios
que demuestran que
e invertir un dólar en mejorar la dieta
en méxico puedes tener rendimientos
económicos y sociales de 20 dólares en
sólo 15 años yo quisiera que nos dijera
un secretario de economía que
inversiones está haciendo que tengan un
rendimiento de 20 dólares en 15 años
porque si no las tiene aquí hay una muy
buena y que puede ayudar mucho al país
el objetivo de mi plática es tratar de
hacerles ver la importancia que tiene el
ambiente obesogénico en la obesidad es
un ambiente tóxico es un ambiente que
genera esta enfermedad
yo quiero convencerles de que las
soluciones al problema de la obesidad de
la diabetes y las enfermedades crónicas
no está en un consultorio con un
nutriólogo ni con un médico y yo soy
médico
en este problema se va a solucionar con
voluntad política y con cambios
estructurales que permitan que todos
nosotros podamos vivir un ambiente más
saludable
es muy triste todo el estigma que se
hace a las personas que tienen obesidad
o que viven con diabetes como tratando
de explicar que la razón de que tengan
esta problemática es por lo que hacen
por su conducta por su estilo de vida y
solemos pensar que puede ser un asunto
de como como comen o a lo mejor a los
mexicanos nos gusta mucho las tortas de
tamal o no nos gusta hacer ejercicio o
nuestra dieta es poco saludable eso no
es cierto
el problema de la obesidad en méxico no
se debe esas razones y yo se los voy a
enseñar esto es lo que hemos hecho en
los últimos años en el instituto hemos
hecho unas encuestas que a lo mejor
ustedes han escuchado que son las
encuestas nacionales de salud y lo rojo
en la población que tiene sobrepeso y
obesidad vean ustedes en el 88 que
poquita población tenía sobrepeso y
obesidad y cuántos tenían un peso
saludable
vean lo que pasó en sólo 11 años del 88
al 99 prácticamente se duplicó la
prevalencia de obesidad y luego del 99
al 2006 siguió subiendo y al 2012 en el
2016 parece estar con cierta
estabilización pero sigue siendo un
problema de rápido crecimiento y en poco
tiempo entonces nos puede decir es que
son los genes de los mexicanos no nos
pueden decir es la cultura mexicana
porque esto es algo que acaba de pasar
la cultura mexicana tiene cientos de
años este no nos puede decir tampoco que
es porque la desidia de las personas no
yo uno de los primeros artículos que
publiqué cuando llegué de boston hace
como 20 años fue después de ver esto el
aumento que hubo en el 99 de diabetes
dije bueno de obesidad vamos a ver cómo
están las muertes por diabetes sí es
cierto que esta obesidad ha aumentado
tanto porque además había incredulidad
sobre si estos datos estaban bien bueno
vamos a ver cómo están las muertes por
diabetes y cuando publique las muertes
por diabetes yo no lo podía creer y
además no era un problema prioritario en
el país pues yo veía que habían
aumentado de una forma increíble que
bueno como están en eeuu eeuu en el país
que todos sabemos que padece mucha
diabetes entonces como están ahí y lo
que vi para mi sorpresa es que eeuu
estaba con una mortalidad por diabetes
mucho menor a la nuestra
lo peor de todo es que el último punto
llegando al 2000 porque esto eso es un
estudio que se hace 18 años llegando al
año 2000 se veía que se disparaba la
diabetes de una forma increíble no me
querían publicar el artículo todo ese
amor es que es un investigador muy joven
a lo mejor se está equivocando oa lo
mejor los datos de los mexicanos son
incorrectos sobre estiman la mortalidad
por diabetes así se veía y bueno no lo
creían me costó mucho trabajo en las
revistas médicas publicar como primer
autor requiere de cierto prestigio de
que te conozcan de que sepan tus
publicaciones lo mandé como a tres
revistas hasta que finalmente una
revista aceptó publicarlo siempre y
cuando pusiera muchas notas de cautela
de estos resultados de que podrían tener
tal vez algún error ahora quiero
enseñarles cómo se ve en los siguientes
años ese punto de inflexión vean el año
2000 como está aquí está el año 2000
la diabetes la mortalidad por diabetes y
siguió creciendo tenemos una mortalidad
por diabetes sumamente alta en el 2016
se habló de una epidemia que requiere
una emergencia epidemiológica pero les
digo que
esto ya lo habíamos dicho en el 2003
pero hasta el 2016 se declaró la
emergencia de diabetes es un desastre lo
que está pasando con la diabetes en el
país hay 14 millones de diabéticos en
mexico 14 millones de diabéticos en
mexico es como más que la población de
muchos países de centroamérica muchos
países de europa y esto no solo nos
preocupa por vivir con diabetes la
mortalidad que se genera es muy grande
imagínense el estadio azteca lleno ya
que hemos estado hablando también un
poco de fútbol esa es la cantidad de
personas que mueren por diabetes todos
los años el estadio azteca lleno eso es
más que ciudades enteras es como si
echara una bomba en una ciudad cada año
eso es lo que está pasando con diabetes
esto genera una carga al país increíble
empobrece al país no podemos desarrollar
la diabetes le da a las personas en la
edad más productiva
solo en los próximos 20 años va a haber
un millón de casos nuevos de diabetes
solo en la ciudad de mexico
el gasto sólo en la ciudad de méxico por
diabetes
actualmente los gastos del costo es un
millón quinientos mil dólares y en estos
veinte años va a subir a perdón mil una
cantidad increíble de recursos muchas
gracias
es una cantidad increíble de hacerlo de
recursos los que se están gastando en la
diabetes ahora
otra cosa que hacemos los epidemiólogos
es tratar de identificar las causas los
mecanismos y proponer soluciones para la
prevenir estos problemas y controlarlos
yo les que decir eso es importante
porque en la actualidad
y recientemente publicamos un estudio
donde de 162 países en los últimos 30
años ninguno ha logrado reducir su
prevalencia de obesidad es un problema
mundial que causó el problema entonces
volvamos a esto es la mala educación de
las personas es la desidia de la gente
es la mala calidad de la dieta no es el
entorno obesogénico en un estudio que
hicimos también a principios del año
2000 empezamos a ver en qué gastaba la
gente en los 80s y en que gastaba la
gente en los noventas y vimos que en el
gasto en los hogares se aumentó el gasto
en refrescos 40 por ciento y disminuyó
el gasto en frutas y verduras 30% esto
fue de los 80s a los 90s porque no
tratamos de informar a la gente que el
consumo de refrescos como tienen mucha
azúcar y están aumentando mucho pueden
estar haciendo daño los refrescos son
ricos en azúcar y el azúcar todo el
mundo lo sabe eso sí crean eso está
demostrado no fue con nosotros eso ya se
sabe en todo el mundo el azúcar en el
refresco produce no solo caries produce
enfermedad cardiovascular diabetes
hipertensión aumenta la mortalidad es un
desastre el azúcar
y este y bueno vamos a ver cómo lo
hacemos
ustedes saben yo desde que soy niño me
recuerdo lo de comer frutas y verduras
aliméntate sanamente toma agua hace
ejercicio eso no sirve no sirve porque
si sirviera estaríamos increíble porque
eso existe desde los setentas se
necesita algo más pusimos en todos los
libros de texto una jarra del buen beber
que le decía a todos los niños en todas
las primarias del país que tenían que
ver sobre tienen estilos de vida
saludables y el ambiente no permite
tener esos estilos de vida entonces
requiere de algo más
yo quiero hacerles una pregunta a todos
los que están aquí quiero que hacen la
mano todos los que consuman por lo menos
un vasito de refresco a la semana alcen
la mano un vasito de refresco no tengan
pena ok
déjela y déjela déjela hay quienes
consumen dos vasitos por lo menos dos
vasitos de refresco vamos a sumarlos
y quienes consumen tres vasitos de
refresco a la semana
bueno miren la definición de alto
consumidor de refresco es un vasito de
refresco a la semana
casi todos ustedes si estamos hablando
de público de alto nivel socioeconómico
y educativo consumen una cantidad de
refresco que si por un adulto a nivel
anual es esto
es 3 litros eso es lo que consume un
cada persona en china al año 3 litros en
promedio per cápita esto es lo que
consumen los mexicanos en promedio al
año eso 167 litros entonces cuando me
dicen oye es que estás exagerando no
puedes satanizar un vasito de refresco
eso lo logran si toman una lata y media
al día y como muchos toman más cuando se
hace el promedio eso es lo que queda
como promedio de los mexicanos entonces
esto no es no es no es chistoso es este
realmente algo que está muy asociado con
la reducción en un país de 126 millones
de mexicanos saben a qué equivale
equivale a miles de toneladas de azúcar
- en nuestra sangre entonces es un éxito
y tan fue un éxito este impuesto al
refresco que muchos países desarrollados
y en vías de desarrollo
tomaron el modelo y la evidencia
mexicana para poner impuestos porque
quien hace las cosas bien en sus países
reino unido- nos llamó y usó nuestra
evidencia y ahora están haciendo un
impuesto no del 10% como nosotros del 35
eeuu fuimos a asesorar distintas
ciudades como berkeley san francisco
pero además estaba
filadelfia y también han puesto
impuestos con mucho éxito
filipinas no sólo puso un impuesto sino
que ha logrado que parte de ese impuesto
se dedique a la salud y estos resultados
pues estaban muy basados en el modelo
mexicano podemos entonces sentirnos
orgullosos que después de 14 años
hayamos logrado no sólo una solución
para el país una solución parcial no va
a resolver la obesidad pero ayuda mucho
y se ha vuelto un ejemplo y un efecto
dominó en el mundo ya no estamos tan
orgullosos porque ya otros países ya lo
hicieron mejor que nosotros
un mayor impuesto un mayor impuesto y
eso es hacerlo mejor hacerlo con más
ganas y nosotros si queremos seguir
haciendo las cosas bien ahora tenemos
que subir ese impuesto ahora sería
ingenuo pensar que lo único que podemos
hacer para combatir la obesidad es el
impuesto hay muchas otras acciones y yo
no tengo tiempo de platicar de todas
ellas a nivel de salud pública hay
cuatro muy importantes una intervenir en
las escuelas los niños son nuestro
futuro y ahorita es una pena pero es más
probable para los niños que están
ahorita en las escuelas llegar a vivir
con diabetes que para los adultos
estamos muy mal en el país y tenemos que
enseñarlos tenemos que hacer un pacto y
todos ser solidarios y tratar de
enseñarnos a tomar agua que lo que toman
los humanos desde hace miles de años de
evolución para hidratarse esto de
hidratarse con bebidas azucaradas no
existía hasta hace cien doscientos años
entonces es algo muy importante trabajar
en las escuelas la otra cosa muy
importante es promover el transporte
activo o sea hacer actividad física no
es ir a un gimnasio por esas hacer pesas
como loco y luego tomarse un licuado
y eso es lo que cree mucha gente que es
no hacer actividad física es si
disfrutar de los momentos de
esparcimiento y de ocio haciendo
ejercicio pero también ir al trabajo
caminando o en bicicleta caminar subir
las escaleras usar el transporte público
y esto es muy importante y sus
sociedades que han sido muy exitosas
como los daneses y los suecos pues uno
puede ver que hay todo el mundo está en
bicicleta hay infraestructura para esto
y eso lo tiene que hacer también con
políticas eso no lo vamos a arreglar los
individuos finalmente quiero hablarles
del ejemplo de chile chile es otro país
que como méxico ha tenido grandes
victorias en la prevención de obesidad
ellos hicieron otro modelo se les
ocurrió hablar de cómo podrían
e informar al consumidor hay unas
etiquetas que se llaman de etiquetado
etiquetado frontal de alimentos las
pantallas no están funcionando ahora ok
bueno nosotros en méxico tenemos unos
globitos en todos los productos que
tienen nueve cifras nosotros los hemos
evaluado en médicos en universitarios
bueno en los que lo hicieron los hemos
evaluado y no lo entienden no se puede
explicar entonces es muy difícil que la
población vaya al súper agarren nuestros
productos y en 20 segundos que es el
tiempo que tarda una persona en el
supere leer una etiqueta tome una
decisión de qué producto es más
saludable lo que hicieron en chile pues
fue muy inteligente en vez de poner
cuatro bolitas o nueve bolitas pusieron
unos sellos de advertencia que dicen
este producto es alto en calorías alto
en azúcar alto en sal alto en grasa esos
sellos de advertencia son un éxito a
nivel mundial no se tienen hasta los
niños nuestro etiquetado no lo entienden
ni los nutriólogos ni los médicos en
chile los niños pueden decir pues este
producto dice alto en azúcar éste no
dice alto en azúcar me llevo el que no
es santo en azúcar
eso se llama a tratar la obesidad con
seriedad y nosotros en méxico un grupo
de expertos ya le dijo a la secretaria
de salud un grupo comisionado por la
secretaria de salud que pensamos que
para méxico se requiere un etiquetado de
advertencia como el chileno y está en
manos de las autoridades ahora pero
tienen toda esta evidencia y toda esta
postura de los expertos académicos la
otra cosa que hizo chile que está
increíble es que quitó a los personajes
de todos los productos que son para
niños es una tragedia que una compañía
transnacional millonaria invierte a todo
el dinero e invierte en un grupo de
expertos en mercadotecnia para pervertir
las mentes de los niños que no son
maduras y no pueden discernir las
verdades de las mentiras ellos tienen
todo y le pueden pagar una estrella a un
futbolista le pueden pagar un cantante a
un héroe a le puede pagar a un equipo de
fútbol para que diga en los nombres de
las playeras toma esa cosa que nos está
matando a todos y que no va a permitir
que pasemos y nos volvamos un país
desarrollado muchos pues no debemos de
permitir esto es ridículo en chile
los productos que tienen un sello de
advertencia no se pueden anunciar en la
televisión no se pueden vender en las
escuelas no se pueden dar a niños ya no
hay tigres en los cereales ni elefantes
ni tucanes ni personajes de la nba ni
futbolistas eso ya se probó en chile y
eso es tratar la obesidad con seriedad y
porque no hemos logrado este tipo de
cosas en mexico y con eso es una de las
reflexiones finales que les quiero hacer
en méxico una de las principales
barreras ha sido la interferencia de la
industria de comida chatarra de bebidas
azucaradas en las políticas yo desde que
estoy trabajando en esto desde el 2003
he visto y he vivido esta interferencia
es muy difícil tratar de sobreponerse a
ella pero existen imagínense ustedes un
comité para combatir el cáncer y que
esté sentados ahí los productores de
cigarros les parece que tiene sentido es
absurdo no bueno en el comité que
discute las políticas para prevenir
obesidad está la cámara de productores y
está la cámara de productores de bebidas
azucaradas y de bienes de consumo
representadas todas las industrias que
generan esta comida chatarra y
obviamente pues es difícil llegar a
acuerdos con ellos se han tenido que
suspender sesiones de expertos varias
veces en esta administración y es muy
difícil llegar a estas soluciones que se
requieren en en conclusión yo les diría
como un mensaje que para lograr hacer un
ambiente donde uno pueda prevenir esta
problemática en méxico donde uno puede
decir bueno quiero alimentarme sanamente
es muy importante que haya un ambiente
más amigable que haya agua disponible
que haya infraestructura para hacer
actividad física que haya
infraestructura para el transporte
activo que haya formas de hidratarse y
bebederos en las escuelas y que haya un
etiquetado que informe al consumidor
sobre los productos poco saludables y
que se prohíba la publicidad que está
dirigida a niños si logramos esto vamos
a lograr desarrollarnos vamos a lograr
salir de la pobreza vamos a lograr mayor
bienestar vamos a lograr disminuir en
millones los años de vida perdidos por
discapacidad que tiene este país
importante vamos a lograr un mejor país
para nuestros hijos que son los que
están ahorita en riesgo y son los que lo
van a sufrir más estos creo que nos
debemos unir como sociedad y apoyar este
tipo de políticas yo con eso concluyo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]